This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加“percent”，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在“Look Back at it”播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听“look back at it”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《The Hard Way》（难走的路）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听“Learn the Hard Way”。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》（受困之爱）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于承担了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们的意义。
for our psychology. Hi everybody. Hello. I'm not going to do my cheery little intro today. I assume that you already know what we're talking about, given that you clicked on this episode, and you probably also have guessed or assumed that this episode is going to be a little bit different,
对我们的心理。大家好。大家好。我今天不打算做欢快的小开场白了。我想既然你点进了这一集，你大概已经知道我们在谈论什么了，你可能也已经猜到或认为这一集会有点不同，
a little bit more vulnerable, open, dare I say, chatty, maybe not chatty, just honest. And, you know, I feel. felt really strange making this episode compared to my usual content. You know, you come here to learn about the psychology of your 20s and the psychology of flirting and breakups and career anxiety and transitions. We're not going to be really doing that today. We're not going to be really having that.
会更加脆弱、开放，我敢说，会更加家长里短、随性一点——也许不是家长里短，只是坦诚。而且，你知道，我觉得。制作这一集让我感觉非常奇怪，与我通常的内容相比。你知道，你来这里是为了解你二十岁的心理学、调情的心理学、分手的心理学、职业焦虑和转型的心理学。我们今天不会真的谈论这些。我们今天不会真正讨论这些。
I'm not going to be having that usual structure and scientific approach. I want to just take a moment to really get you guys up to speak. feed on what I've been going through. You know, for a long time, I've been doing this podcast for a very long time. And along that journey, I've been, I would hope, transparent around what is going on in my own personal life. Sometimes I've tried to, you know, create more of a distance or a space between my personal life and what I talk about on the show.
我不会采用那种通常的结构和科学的方法。我只想花一点时间，真正让大家了解我一直在经历的事情。你知道，很长一段时间以来，我一直在做这个播客，已经做了很长时间了。在这段旅程中，我一直希望，我希望自己能对个人生活中发生的事情保持透明。有时我曾试图，你知道，在我的个人生活和我节目中谈论的内容之间拉开更多的距离或留出空间。
But it's very hard for it not to kind of infiltrate and come to the surface. the topics and the ideas and the opinions that I express are all derived from personal experience. And because of that, it felt strange just moving on with regularly scheduled programming and not talking about something pretty serious and hard that I've been through recently, which is that I basically had a mental breakdown. There it is. I said it out loud. I had a really, really rough time this past month that has completely really shaken me to my core
但这些内容很难不渗透进来并浮出水面。我表达的主题、想法和观点都源于个人经历。正因为如此，如果只是继续按既定节目安排进行，而不谈论我最近经历的一些非常严重且艰难的事情——也就是我基本上精神崩溃了——我会觉得很奇怪。就是这样。我大声说出来了。过去的一个月里，我度过了一段非常非常艰难的时期，这彻底震撼了我的核心，
and has kind of made me reconsider my place in the world, made me reconsider mental health in a complete new light, spiritual health in a new light, you know, this decade in a new life. And I really want to kind of share what that was like, what that experience. was like going through it for those of you who might be going through something similar. And like I said, I really debated talking about this. It is so just inherently vulnerable. But, you know, I've spoken about breakups. I've spoken about grief.
并且在某种程度上让我以全新的一道光芒重新审视我在世界上的位置，以全新的一道光芒重新审视心理健康，以全新的一道光芒审视精神健康，你知道，以全新的一道光芒审视这个十年。我真的很想和大家分享那种感觉，那种经历。对于那些可能正在经历类似事情的人来说，经历这一切是怎样的。就像我说的，我真的纠结过要不要谈论这件事。它是如此自然地脆弱。但是，你知道，我谈论过分手。我谈论过悲伤。
I've spoken about, you know, losing family members. I've spoken about my physical health. And why does, you know, the ball have to stop there? Why do we then tend to shy away when it comes to talking about? our mental health with the same openness and authenticity and honesty that we would discuss all these other topics and all these other experiences of this decade. This is my reality at the moment. It's something that I'm going through.
我谈论过，你知道，失去亲人。我谈论过我的身体健康。为什么，你知道，这就必须戛然而止呢？为什么当谈到讨论我们的心理健康时，我们往往会退缩，不能像讨论所有这些其他主题以及这个十年代的所有这些其他经历那样，抱持同样的开放性、真实性和诚实呢？这是我目前的现实。这是我正在经历的事情。
And as sad as it is, unfortunate as it is, I also know that there are many of you who are probably going through this as well. and you feel so completely, entirely alone. And so whilst like this podcast is obviously about providing science and evidence in this self-help space and giving you like factual wellness content, it's also about community and it's also about being able to see your experiences reflected back in thousands, if not millions of others. you know, whatever you're struggling with, I think there is a huge comfort that comes from knowing that you are not alone in that experience, that there is someone somewhere, elsewhere, who is navigating the same challenges as you are.
尽管它令人悲伤，尽管它令人不幸，但我也知道你们当中有很多人可能也在经历这一切。而你感觉自己是那么的完全、彻底地孤立无援。所以，尽管这个播客显然是关于在自助领域提供科学和证据，并为你提供基于事实的健康内容的，但它也是关于社区的，也是关于能够看到你的经历在成千上万、甚至数百万其他人身上得到反映。你知道，无论你正在与什么挣扎，我认为只要知道在这段经历中你并不孤单，在某个地方、在其他地方有另一个人正在经历与你相同的挑战，就会带来巨大的慰藉。
The big problem I find, or the big hurdle I find with talking about, you know, mental health very explicitly and, you know, not just saying, yeah, I have mental health struggles, but being like, no, I've had, a full, you know, mental breakdown, prolonged depressive episode, massive anxiety, is that you do still recognize the stigma that is attached. Even in this space, even though I've made, and you know, this is my career, I talk about psychology, talking about psychology and talking about the very real lived experience of mental health is quite different and is opening yourself. up to a lot of misunderstanding. And that's something that I've kind of accepted in talking about this today is that, you know, people could listen to this and just be like, hi, like, what is she
我发现的巨大问题，或者我在谈论（你知道的）心理健康时发现的巨大障碍——不仅仅是说“是的，我有心理健康问题”，而是说“不，我有过全面的（你知道的）精神崩溃、长期的抑郁发作、巨大的焦虑”——在于你确实仍然能认出其中附带的污名。即使在这个领域，即使我已经做过（你知道的，这是我的职业，我谈论心理学），谈论心理学和谈论心理健康的真实生活经验是完全不同的，这会让自己面临很多误解。而这也是我今天在谈论这件事时已经接受的一点，那就是，你知道，人们听了可能会觉得，“嗨，这到底是什么？”
talking about? Or maybe people will listen to this and be like, well, I'm, you know, I'm not going to listen to such an untrustworthy narrator from now on, you know, she's not talking about mental health in like, you know, in like a guarded way. She's talking about it very openly and with great realness and that can be really confronting for some people. So I would just ask for grace. This episode is not structured. It's going to be a bit of a ramble. And I've kind of accepted that some people might be shocked to hear this.
她在说些什么？”或者也许人们听了会觉得，“嗯，我（你知道的）从现在起不会再听这样一个不可信的叙述者了，（你知道的）她谈论心理健康的方式一点也不（你知道的）有所保留。她谈论得非常公开，而且非常真实，这对外人来说可能会非常有对立感或冲击力。”所以我只想请求大家的包容。这一集没有结构。它会有些漫无边际。而我已经接受了这一点，有些人听到可能会感到震惊。
Some people might be confronted. So just check on yourself as to where you are. And if you think this will be helpful, please listen on. If you just want to know what it's like, I guess, or to see or to be able to provide help for someone else who you know who might be going through the same experience, that is really my ultimate goal here is to provide a lived experience for you to reflect on in your own life when you confront scary topics such as, and scary ideas, such as the ones that I've been working through.
有些人可能会感到受到冲击。所以，请自我审视一下你目前的状态。如果你认为这会有所帮助，请继续收听。如果你只是想知道这是怎么回事，我想，或者去看看，或者能够为你知道的、可能正在经历同样经历的另一个人提供帮助，这才是我在这里的最终目标：为你提供一个可以反思的生活经验，当你在自己的生活中面对像我一直在努力解决的那些可怕的话题和可怕的想法时，可以有所借鉴。
If you have been listening for a while, you'll know that every now and again I give like a mental health update because this is like a mental health podcast and a few months ago I even gave like an update where I was like I'm doing so well I'm thriving I'm living my best life I'm like going off my antidepressants like everything is good we're making forward progress and then things changed as they very often do with our brains and our minds and our perception and our and our health you think you're doing really very well but one of the realities of living with a mental health condition is that kind of in the back of your mind you always know that there is there is a time that will come where it could get worse and so even if you are feeling amazing and fabulous and
如果你听了一段时间，你就会知道，每隔一段时间我就会提供一次心理健康更新，因为这是一个心理健康播客，几个月前我甚至还做过一次更新，当时我说：“我状态太好了，我在蓬勃发展，我在过我最好的生活，我正在戒掉抗抑郁药，一切都很好，我们正在取得进展。”然后事情就变了，就像我们的脑海、思想、感知和健康经常发生的那样，你觉得自己做得真的非常好，但患有心理健康状况的现实之一是，在你的脑海深处，你总是知道会有那么一天，情况可能会变得更糟糕。所以，即使你感觉惊艳绝伦、
enjoying life it's a there's a hesitancy there is a sense of like tiptoeing around that experience like oh how long is this going to last how long am i going to feel like this because you know that the other shoe might eventually drop you know you might get bad again and you hope not but that is the case and that is what happened with me i went from being super super happy and then there was just this slow descent and always in hindsight can you see the path that you've taken right in the moment you just want to survive and push forward you're hoping that it's like home or contextual or it's just because you're really stressed and then the stress fades and then you know the days go on and it's like oh i just can't get these thoughts out of my head my biggest fixation
享受生活，内心也会有一种犹豫，有一种如履薄冰的感觉——“哦，这会持续多久？我这种感觉会持续多久？”因为你知道另一只靴子终究会掉下来（坏事可能会再次发生），你知道情况可能会再次变糟，虽然你希望不会，但事实就是如此，这就是发生在我身上的事情。我从超级超级快乐，然后就开始了缓慢的下坡路。而且只有事后诸葛亮，你才能看到自己走过的路，对吧？在当下，你只想活下去并继续前进。你希望这只是暂时的、特定环境的，或者只是因为你压力太大了，然后压力消散了，然后（你知道的）日子一天天过去，感觉就像是“哦，我就是无法把这些想法赶出脑海”。我最大的执念，
and the thing that really culminated in me really kind of just not being able to cope for a while there had to do with thoughts and anxieties around death i have very intense death anxiety feels weird to say that out loud. I'm sure some of you may have realized that or guessed it, but it's not something I talk about that much because, to be honest, talking about it, it like puts it, like you squarely have to face it and it's right there and it's like an incredibly terrible, inevitable fear. It's, I think, the most profound fear to fear death because everything else in life, you know, you can kind of avoid or you can, change your behaviors to avoid and death is one of those things that you just can't and you have to
真正导致我有一段时间无法应对的事情，与对死亡的想法和焦虑有关。我有非常强烈的死亡焦虑。大声说出这句话感觉怪怪的。我确信你们中的有些人可能已经意识到了这一点或猜到了，但这并不是我经常谈说的事，因为老实说，谈论它，就像把它摆出来一样，你必须直面它，它就在那里，这是一种极其可怕、不可避免的恐惧。我认为，害怕死亡是所有恐惧中最深刻的恐惧，因为生活中的其他一切，你知道，你都可以某种程度上避开，或者你可以改变行为来避开，而死亡是那种你根本无法避开的事物。你必须
try and find a way to create a meaning in a finite life and to, you know, have some form of comfort or vision or value or life philosophy that lets you push forward. And I just kind of lost that. I just no longer could access my purpose and my meaning and my life philosophy around why are we here, what are we doing here? Life is just this big inconvenient, meaningless thing and it almost felt like the universe was like collapsing in on me. Like I'd be lying in bed and it was just like the absolute terror of knowing that this thing that you're terrified of is going to happen to you. and then the equal terror of knowing that, you know, there's nothing you can do about it. And no matter what you think about it, like it doesn't change, what's going to happen. And yeah, so gosh, dark, very, very dark.
努力寻找一种方法，在有限的生命中创造意义，并拥有某种形式的慰藉、愿景、价值观或生活哲学，让你能够继续前进。而我当时有点失去了这种能力。我再也无法触及我的目标、我的意义、以及关于“我们为什么来这里、我们在这里做什么”的生活哲学。生命只是这个巨大的、不便的、毫无意义的事情，它几乎让我感觉宇宙正在向我压塌下来。就像我躺在床上，那种绝对的恐惧感挥之不去：我知道这件让你感到恐惧的事情将要发生在你身上，
And I think it's something that we all have at the back of our minds, right? Everyone knows this. There are just times in your life where you feel more, it's kind of like, how do I explain it? it's like there's this weird fuzzy film like a fuzzy transparent curtain between you and thinking about death and most of the time you know we've got our back turned to the curtain and we're enjoying everything that's in life and then other times you turn around and you you peek behind the curtain and it's just so just incomprehensible um that it really starts to get you down and then for me things come up around time and meaning and love and connection and fear of seeing
而另一种同等可怕的感觉是，你知道，对此你无能为力。无论你怎么想，它都不会改变即将发生的事情。是的，天哪，黑暗，非常非常黑暗。而且我认为这是我们所有人脑海深处都有的一种东西，对吧？每个人都知道这一点。生活中总会有那么一些时刻，你会觉得更……这有点像，我该怎么解释呢？这就好像在你和对死亡的思考之间，有一层奇怪的毛茸茸的薄膜、一层毛茸茸的透明窗帘，大多数时候（你知道的），我们的背是对着窗帘的，我们正在享受生活中的一切，然后有时你转过身，你偷看了窗帘后面，它是如此的难以理解，以至于它真的开始让你情绪低落。然后对我来说，事情开始围绕着时间、意义、爱、连接、以及害怕看到
people I love pass away and you can see how the ball gets rolling real real quick really really quickly I think the only time I haven't had these fears has been when I was someone who was quite spiritual and religious you know and suddenly not suddenly and I just am not anymore it's just part of the life journey and the transition that I've gone through where I just no longer saw myself in the home of religion. I see its value. I see the value of spirituality, but it's just the current structures that are presented to me. Like I just don't really relate to them. I'm kind of a woman of science. Sometimes I don't really feel like it makes sense. And I think that that detachment from a spiritual understanding of my life really has contributed to these cycles of
我爱的人离去而展开，你可以看到事情是如何迅速地、非常非常迅速地开始失控的。我想我唯一没有这种恐惧的时候，是我曾经是一个相当灵性、有宗教信仰的人，（你知道的）突然之间——也不是突然之间，我只是不再那样了——这只是我经历过的人生旅程和转变的一部分，我不再在宗教的归宿中看到自己。我看到了它的价值。我看到了灵性的价值，但只是目前呈献给我的这些结构。就像我只是真的和它们没有共鸣。我算是个科学女性。有时我真的觉得它说不通。而且我认为这种与我的生命的灵性理解的脱节，确实促成了这些
really existential negative, incomprehensible thoughts. The point where I really started to realize, like, oh no, like this is not going the way it should. And I've gone through this before and it's like, you can really, there's like a, it's like a, it's like a flight path, right? Like there's like a a journey and you can like see the roadblocks and you like kind of know what. coming and you know that like once you get to a certain stage it's like you know shit like there's no turning back and when I realized that was when I was in Bali before I went to Bali I was so busy I had so much going on that it really meant that I couldn't really think about anything bigger or more profound than the present and what was happening right now and then I went on vacation I went on holiday
真正存在主义的、负面的、不可理解的想法的循环。当我真正开始意识到“哦不，这不对劲，事情没有按应有的方向发展”时，我已经经历过这种情况了，这就像是，你可以真切地感受到，这就像是一条飞行路线，对吧？就像是一段旅程，你可以看到路障，你有点知道会发生什么，而且你知道一旦你到了某个阶段，那就完蛋了——（你知道的）糟糕，没有回头路了。当我意识到这一点时，我正在巴厘岛。去巴厘岛之前，我太忙了，有太多事情要做，这意味着我真的无法思考任何比当下以及正在发生的事情更大、更深远的事情。然后我去度假了。我去度假了，
interestingly I was really excited of course not interestingly obviously I was very excited I was very excited to just like spend time with my mom and my cousin and my auntie and relax by the pool and drink pina calatas and go on hikes and like see the sites and go to the markets and actually what ended up happening was all the things that were keeping me anchored to the present and by that I mean my stress was lifted and suddenly all the thoughts that I'd been trying very hard to push down and suppress came flooding in and I did not have the tools to deal with it. I spent, Bali was amazing, but I spent a lot of time in my own head, in my brain, overworking and overthinking, concepts, ideas, big ideas about the universe and the world and purpose.
有趣的是，我当然很兴奋——不是有趣，很显然，我非常兴奋。我非常兴奋能和妈妈、表姐、阿姨一起度过时光，在泳池边放松，喝皮纳科达鸡尾酒，去徒步旅行，看看景点，去逛市场。而最终发生的事情却是，所有那些将我锚定在当下的事物——我指的是我的压力——都被解除了，突然之间，那些我一直极力压抑和克制、试图推开的想法如潮水般涌来，而我却没有应对这些工具。我花了……巴厘岛很棒，但我花了很多时间沉浸在自己的头脑、自己的大脑中，过度思考那些概念、想法、关于宇宙、世界、目标、
and life and God and religion. Not a fun place to be. I think those thoughts have their time and place, but they should really be explored when you feel mentally prepared for them. My problem was that I hadn't provided myself with the space or the mental capacity to think about it, to think about it when I needed to think about it at a time when I was more able to deal with how confronting it could be. And so I always say this, you can avoid and you can avoid and you can avoid and you can
生活、上帝和宗教的大想法。那可不是什么好呆的地方。我认为这些想法有它们的时间和地点，但只有当你觉得自己精神上做好了准备去探索它们时，才应该去探索。我的问题在于，我没有为自己提供空间或心理容量去思考它，在需要思考它的时候去思考它——也就是在我更有能力应对它的冲击力的那个时候。所以我总是这么说：你可以逃避，你可以逃避，你可以逃避，你可以
avoid but it will come up at the most inconvenient time and that is what happened then i went to new york i remember walking around the streets of new york and just being like i really wish i could be having fun right now but everything feels so impermanent and everything just feels so tragic and terrifying and it's kind of like you cannot see the world except for from this place of finality and this place of I don't know, that everything will eventually be gone. And that imbues all of your experiences. Everything that you perceive is imbued with this tinge of like sadness, even sadness for the fact that one day this will be gone, you know,
逃避，但它总会在最不合时宜的时候浮现出来。这就是当时发生的事情。后来我去了纽约。我记得走在纽约的街道上，心里只想著：我现在真的好想开心起来，但一切都显得那么无常，一切都那么悲惨和可怕。那种感觉就像是，你除了从这种终结感和这种……我不知道，最终一切都会消失的角度出发，就无法看待世界。这种感觉浸透了你的所有经历。你所感知的每件事都浸透了这种淡淡的悲伤，甚至为有一天这一切终将消失而感到悲伤，（你知道的）
even though right now it isn't. It's very, very like mentally complicated. And I think it really comes from like a detachment with the present. I made an episode a couple of weeks back, maybe like a month now that was like the power of staying present. really that was me trying to remind myself of that power and trying to reinforce my own habits when it came to this but by the time i got back to australia like things were not going well things were not working out for me and i entered this pretty dark place where i could not really
尽管现在它还没有消失。这在心理上非常非常复杂。而且我认为这确实源于与当下的脱节。几周前我做了一集节目——大概一个月前了吧——主题是“保持当下的力量”。其实那是我在试图提醒自己这种力量，并在遇到这种情况时努力强化我自己的习惯。但当我回到澳大利亚时，情况已经很不妙了，事情对我很不顺，我进入了一个相当黑暗的境地，我无法真正
make sense of reality not in the sense that i was like experiencing psychosis or anything but it just was like everything was very clouded. Everything was overruled by constant repetitive thinking in a thought spiral. It began to really make me want to withdraw. I think my biggest fear when I'm going through a bit of an existential mental breakdown, whatever you want to call it, is passing it on to someone else. I know this sounds very, very strange, but sometimes I believe, you know, that my thoughts could be contagious and that you're going to say something to someone that they've never considered before
理解现实。不是说我出现了精神病之类的症状，而是感觉一切都被严重遮蔽了。一切都被思维风暴中持续不断的重复思考所主导。这开始让我非常渴望退缩。我想当我在经历某种存在主义的精神崩溃——无论你想怎么称呼它——时，我最大的恐惧就是把它传染给别人。我知道这听起来非常非常奇怪，但有时我相信（你知道的）我的想法可能是会传染的，你会对某人说一些他们以前从未考虑过的事情，这会真的吓到他们。而这正是我真正害怕的地方——我可能会把别人也拖入这种境地和这种黑暗、向下的思维风暴中。所以我对此保持沉默了一段时间，为了我自己的利益而保持了极度的沉默。然后我开始告诉我男朋友，但这多少带点笑声和咯咯的笑声，（你知道的）比如“哦，我这疯狂的大脑。不管怎样，我不想谈这个。我们继续吧。”我总是感到很着迷，我明明知道该怎么做，对吧？我有工具、有策略，我知道如何应对这样一种情况。其中一个主要的支柱、你能为自己做的最好的事情之一，就是敞开心扉，分担负担。
and it's going to really scare them. And that is what really scares me is that I could plunge someone else into this situation and this dark, downward thought spiral. So I stayed silent about it for a while, very silent at my own detriment. Then I started telling my boyfriend, but it was kind of with a laugh and a giggle and, you know, like, oh, my crazy brain. Anyhow, I don't want to talk about it. Let's move on. It always fascinates me that I know what to do, right? I have the tools, the strategies, I know how to work through a situation like this. And one of the main pillars and one of the best things you can do for yourself is to open up and is to share the burden.
但这说起来容易做起来难。你甚至觉得自己没有资格。你不想让别人走进来，因为那需要你承认自己的处境很糟糕。这就是我的感受，我会这么说，因为事实就是如此。然后事情就像突然翻转了一样。有一天晚上我们出去了，和我的好闺蜜们一起出去喝酒。当时我心想：我本该是世界上最开心的人，在任何时候都是——我有最漂亮的朋友，我在这个美丽的城市里。结果第二天醒来时我陷入了恐慌，我的全身都在颤抖，我卡住了。我卡住了，我卡住了，我陷在自己的思绪里，我卡在这个想法里。这几乎就像是在度过一天，而脑子里只有
It's a lot easier said than done. You don't feel like you have the right almost. You don't want to let people in because that would require you acknowledging that your situation is bad. that is how I'll say it because that is how it was and then it was like almost a flip switched we went out one night went out drinking with like my best friends it's like I should be the happiest I've ever been in the world ever been at any time like I have the most beautiful friends I'm in this beautiful city and I woke up the next day in a panic and my whole body was shaking and I was stuck I was stuck I was stuck in my mind and I was stuck in this thought and it's almost like walking through a day and it's just
死亡、死亡、死亡、死亡。真是难得要命。也就是在那时我意识到我真的需要一些帮助。幸运的是我妈妈当时在镇上，所以她最终取消了这周剩下的所有工作安排，留下来陪我。我男朋友也留下来陪我——好吧，我们基本上住在一起，但他每天晚上都会从工作的地方赶回来抱抱我，因为我不想离开我的房间。我不想离开我的房子。一切都那么混乱、压抑、喧闹。“喧闹”大概是我能对它做出的最好描述了。而且孤独、孤立。你只觉得自已漂浮在太空中，没有其他人能理解你的经历，你感到了绝对的恐惧，你不知道该如何回到
like death death death death pretty freaking hard and that's when I realized that I really needed some help luckily my mom was in town so she ended up canceling like all of her work engagements for the rest of the week and stayed with me and my boyfriend stayed with me well we basically lived together but he would come back from work every single night and just hold me because I didn't didn't want to leave my room. I didn't want to leave my house. Everything was just confusing and overwhelming and loud. Loud is probably the best way I can describe it and lonely and isolating. You just feel like you are floating in space and no one else can understand your experience and you're just absolutely terrified and you don't know how you're going to get back to like the
现实的母舰和理性的母舰。所以我妈妈来陪了我一个星期，然后把接力棒交给了我爸爸，爸爸又来陪了我一个星期。在那两个星期的周期里，我无法吃东西，无法睡觉。而当我确实睡着时，醒来时也是浑身大汗、瑟瑟发抖，就是不想离开房子，真真正正地处于一种木僵状态。就像我只会坐在墙角盯着墙壁发呆。拼命想去工作，拼命想去健身房、去上陶艺课、去见朋友。但这根本不可能。当时的我根本做不到这一切。另一件事是澳大利亚的心理健康服务获取渠道——我假设其他地方也是如此。
mothership of reality and the mothership of rationality. as well. So my mom came and stayed with me for a week and then passed the baton over to my dad who came and stayed with me for another week. And that two-week period involved me not being able to eat, not being able to sleep. And then when I did sleep, waking up in a sweat and shaking, just not wanting to leave the house, genuinely just being in a catatonic state. Like I would just sit in bed and stare at the wall. Trying really hard to do work, trying really hard to go to the gym and to go to my pottery classes and to see friends. And it was not possible. It was not happening for me at that time. The other thing was mental health access in Australia and I'm going to assume this is everywhere.
简直糟透了。简直是糟透了。我打了危机求助热线，我会大方承认，我认为危机热线是非常棒的生命线。如果你在澳大利亚，我相信美国、英国和其他地方也有其他危机热线，生命线真的很了不起，但这次经历却一点也不了不起。因为我给那个女人打电话时说：“我需要看精神科医生，我需要看紧急心理医生。我需要对某件事获得帮助，求求你了。我该怎么做？”就好像我明知该怎么做，可连我都无法获得我需要的帮助。我当时在试着找心理学家。我试着找精神科医生。等待期居然是六个月。我等不了六个月。我现在正在受苦。我觉得这太不合理了。
It's absolutely abysmal. It's literally abysmal. I called a crisis line, which I'll openly admit, I think crisis lines are amazing lifeline. If you're in Australia, I'm sure there are. other crisis lines in the U.S. and the UK and elsewhere, life lines are incredible, but this experience was not incredible because I called this woman and I was like, I need to see a psychiatrist, I need to see an emergency psychologist. I need help with something, please. Like, what do I do? It was like, I knew what to do and I, even I could not get the help I needed. Like, I was trying to find a psychologist. I was trying to find a psychiatrist. It was like six month's wait period. I can't wait six months. Like I'm suffering right now. I like that's unreasonable.
这简直不合理，但我也理解这个系统的压力。你打电话给心理学家，对方却说：“哦，我不想接你的案子。对不起，我没有名额。我没有名额。”我打过电话的一个中心——我不会点出它们的名字，但天哪，它们真的太糟糕了。它们真的太糟糕了。我打电话过去说：“发生了这些事。”然后他们说：“对不起，我们帮不了你。”我说：“你能把我转介给别人吗？”他们说“不能”。后来我妈妈又给他们回了电话，突然他们就有了适合她的预约，却没有适合我的预约，因为（你知道的）我理解这一点——尊重你们的界限，尊重你们的平静。但这正是那种让人觉得“我是不可治愈的吗？这难道就是你们的暗示吗？因为你们是一家私营诊所所以不接受我的病例……”你懂这个系统，但是，是的，
That's just unreasonable, but I also understand the pressures on the system. You call psychologists to be like, oh, I don't want to take your case. Sorry, I don't have a space. I don't have a space. There was one center that I called. And I'm not going to name them, but oh my God, were they just absolutely terrible. They were absolutely terrible. And I called them and I was like, this is what's happening. And they were like, sorry we can't help you and I was like can you refer me to someone else they're like no and then later on my mum called them back up and suddenly they had an appointment for her but not an appointment for me because you know I understand it like respect your boundaries respect your peace but it was one of those things where it's like am I untreatable is that what you are implying and not accepting my case because you are
我打了这个求助热线寻求帮助。我说：“这就是我需要的。”她居然对我说：“哦，（你知道的）你在吸毒吗？”我说：“没有。”（这倒是个重要的常规问题。）我说：“没有，我没有吸毒。”“你在经历酒精戒断吗？”“没有。”然后你能看出她有点困惑，于是她说：“你最近看过什么恐怖电影吗？”我简直不敢相信她会问我这个问题。我说：“没有，我没看过什么恐怖电影。我心理不健康。我知道自己出了什么问题，这可不是因为我看过《惊声尖叫4》。”这真是一次大开眼界的经历，也再次让我认识到我们的系统实际上有多么糟糕和落后。
a private clinic you get the system but yeah I called this helpline and I'm asking for help I'm like this is what I need. And she genuinely said to me, oh, you know, are you on drugs? I was like, no, it's an important question to ask. I was like, no, not on any drugs. Are you having like withdrawals from alcohol? No. And then you could see that she was like a bit puzzled and she was like, have you watched any scary movies lately? I could not believe that she asked me that question. I was like, no, I haven't watched any scary movies. I'm mentally unwell. Like, I know what's wrong with me and it's not because I've watched Green 4. Like it was just this very eye-opening experience and a re-acknowledgment of how terrible and
怎么说呢——如果你是一个……我不想自称专家，但我以谈论心理学为生。我也曾在澳大利亚的心理健康系统工作过。我曾参与设计过其中一些系统——比如设计系统，尤其是针对儿童的系统——而我却无法在这个系统中导航。那世界上到底还有谁能做到这一点？谁能找到他们需要的帮助？
poor our systems actually are. How, and if, you know, I'm someone who is, I don't want to say an expert, but I talk about psychology for a living. I also used to work in Australia's mental health system. I helped design some of these systems. like design, especially for children, and I cannot navigate this system. Who in the world is meant to be able to do that? Who is meant to find the help that they need?
最终她对我说：“哦，你可以去急诊室。”如果你是一个正在经历围绕死亡焦虑的危机的人，急诊室绝对是最糟糕的地方。她的这个建议简直糟糕透顶，但我体谅她可能工作过度，而且他们已经在尽力而能了。他们每天要和数百、数十个经历各异的人交谈，所以我对她充满全盘的尊重。但这并不是我需要的帮助。
And eventually she was like, oh, you can go to the emergency room. And the emergency room is the worst place to be if you are someone having a crisis around death anxiety. Literally terrible suggestion from her, but I appreciate she was probably very overworked and they're doing the best they can. They talk to hundreds, dozens of people a day. who have very unique experiences, so full respect to her. It just wasn't the help that I needed.
这感觉像是一种僵局。这感觉绝对是一场僵局。我可以继续解释那种经历是怎样的，但它真的太缺乏任何令人兴奋的东西了。没有什么可报道的。就像是坐在床上，每30分钟哭一次，盯着天花板，不跟任何朋友说话，真的不想吃东西，无法入睡，
And it felt like a stalemate. It felt like an absolute stalemate. I could go on and explain more of what that experience was like, but it was just genuinely so devoid of anything exciting. There's nothing to report. Like it's sitting in bed, crying every 30 minutes, staring at the ceiling, not talking to any of your friends, not really wanting to eat, not being able to sleep,
只有完全的身体和精神疲惫，这是我能做出的唯一解释。那个真正帮了我、把我拉出泥潭的人——其实是三个人：我的父母和我的伴侣。我无法想象，不得不看着一个人什么都不想做、不想动、无法获得需要的帮助、在这么长的时间里感到如此可怕的压倒性焦虑，会有多么 stressful（压力山大）。
just complete physical and mental exhaustion is the only way I can explain it. The person who helped me, so so much who got me through this, was, well, three people was my parents and my partner. I cannot imagine how stressful it would have been just having to watch someone not want to do anything, not want to move, not be able to get the help that they needed, just be so terribly overwhelmed for like this extended period of time.
但他们就是那些说：“不，我们要设定小目标，我们今天只是离开房子，我们要去散步，我们要去动物收容所跟狗狗玩耍”的人。我妈妈甚至说：“也许我应该给你买只狗。”我当时就想——有一部分的我……这太搞笑了。我当时已经快从那个状态里走出来了，心想：嗯，我知道这可能不是个好决定。就像不要在饥饿时去买食品杂货、不要在感情破裂时生个孩子、不要在经历心理健康危机时养狗一样，这是三大戒律。而正是他们真正帮我度过了难关。他们接了一个又一个电话，寻找任何能尽快给我看病的人——尽管那依然需要等上两三周，但这已经是我们能找到的最快的了。他们去帮我
But they were the ones who were like, nope, we're going to set small goals, we're just going to leave the house today, we're going to go for a walk, we're going to go to the animal shelter and play with some dogs. My mom was even like, maybe I should get you a dog. And I was like, part of me, like, it was so funny. I was kind of coming out of it by that stage and I was like, hmm I probably I know that that is probably not a great decision it's like don't go food shopping when you're hungry don't have a baby when your relationship is falling apart don't get a dog when you're having a mental health crisis that is the three cardinal rules and they were the ones who really got me through it they were the ones who took phone call after phone call who found anyone someone who could see me as soon as possible which was still into like was still two to a two to a three weeks away, but that was the closest that we could get. They went and, you know, filled my
拿处方药，把冰箱塞满食物，为我做饭，确保我需要什么就有什么。还有我的朋友们，天哪，我的朋友们。回想起来真是又有趣又感人：我当时就坐在后院里，为这个世界感觉如此毫无意义而哭泣，然而人们却依然出现并向我展示他们爱我——世上难道还有比这更有意义的事吗？我的朋友梅格把花放在我家门口，我的朋友萨拉带我出去——简直像说“哦，我愿意为你做任何事”一样，她试着——她基本上每天都打电话给我。我的朋友凯特查看我的情况，给我发短视频——就像我朋友们所做的那样，他们所有人都对我关怀备至，确保我知道我在他们心上，
medication scripts for me, filled the fridge with food, cooked for me, made sure that whatever I kind of needed, I had. And then my friends, my, oh my gosh, my friends, it'd be so interesting and funny that I would be just sitting out in my backyard, crying about how meaningless this world felt and yet people would show up and show that they loved me and isn't that the most meaningful thing ever my friend meg dropped flowers at my door my friend sarah took me on like was like oh i'll come and do anything for you like she tried she called me like basically every single day my friend kate like checked in on me sent me reels like my like my friend stuff like all of them were just so there for me and made sure that they that i knew that i was in their thoughts
而且我可以和他们谈心，我可以联系到他们。但他们同时也尊重我想要当隐士的事实。公平地说，我其实不需要，但那就是我的倾向，我的本能就是躲起来。他们尊重这一点。并且他们持续地向我伸出援手。我认为当某人的心理健康状况真的很糟糕时，这是一个大问题。如果你是他们的朋友并且你知道这一点，
and that I could talk to them, that I could reach them. But they also respected the fact that I kind of needed to hermit. To be fair, I didn't need to, but that was my inclination, that was my instinct, was to hide away. And they respected that. And they continued to reach out. I think it's a big problem when someone is really going through it with their mental health. Like if you are their friend and you know it,
但你却指望他们必须主动联系你，那就“嗯，这不会发生”。那恰恰是他们脑子里最不会想到的事。这就好像要求一个脊椎骨折的朋友来跟你一起去散步一样。这不是他们脑子里想的事。这不是他们有能力去问候你的事。维持友谊是极其困难的，这并不是说没有渴望、需求和长久的思念，但当你的生活完全失去了意义、爱和快乐感，
but you expect them to have to reach out for you, it's like, well, that's not going to happen. That's just, that is like the least, the last thing that they're thinking about. It's like asking like a friend with like, you know, a fractured spine to like come and go for a walk with you. It's like that's not what they're thinking about. That's not something that they're capable of checking in with you. Maintaining friendships is incredibly difficult and it's not that there isn't a desire and a need and a longing. but when everything in your life is just completely devoid of meaning and love and a sense of joy
并且你觉得自己彻底崩溃时，那些友谊——尽管你确实在乎它们——你不会去考虑一个月不和某人说话的后果。你不会去想这对你们的关系会造成什么影响。你只是在努力熬过每一天。所以这是一个很好的提醒，也是对我的提醒：如果你有一个朋友正在经历艰难时期，主动联系他们吧。这并不尴尬。大不了，（你知道的）他们可能不会回复你，但至少他们收到了那条消息。而且
and you just feel completely broken, like those friendships as much as you do care about them, like you don't think about the consequence of not talking to someone for a month. You don't think about what that's going to do to your relationship. You're just trying to get through it. So it's a good reminder, and it was a reminder for me. Like if you have a friend going through a rough time, just reach out. It's not embarrassing. quid, you know, they just might not reply to you, but at least they have that message. And there's
我从来没有和任何人聊过，对方会说：“哦，我真希望当初没人联系我。我真希望我得到的支持少一点。我真希望知道爱我的人少一点。”事情根本不是这样的。所以这是一个非常宝贵、非常宝贵的教训。另一个宝贵的教训对我和我来说是：药物治疗真的、真的很重要。而且我认为我的很多问题。状况是由某种生物学原因引起的。我知道有很多不同的建议与此有关，与SSRI（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）或抗抑郁药的疗效和成功率有关。只要选择对你有效的方法就好。
no one who I've ever spoken to who's been like, oh, I wish that someone hadn't reached out. I wish that I had less support. I wish that I'd known less people loved me. Like, it's not how it works. So that was like a really valuable, valuable lesson. Another valuable lesson was for me, medication is really, really important. And I do think that a lot of my problem is problem. condition is derived from something biological. And I know that there are a lot of different suggestions to do with this and to do with the efficacy and the success of SSRIs or antidepressants. Just do what works for you.
有很多研究，也有很多新的研究表明，其他方法也非常有用，更多的认知心理疗法或谈话疗法也很有用。对我和我来说，情况并非如此。看看我的生活，一切其实都相当壮观，而且我很幸运能拥有我所拥有的。对我而言，你几乎能注意到一种生物学上的转变，因为你生活中的其他一切其实都没有变，然后突然之间你就掉进了这个深坑里，而你却不知道该如何爬出来。所以药物治疗真的很有用，这感觉就像是——这太奇怪了——我几乎在为自己设定每天的小目标。但这一次不是为了在事业上取得进展，也不是为了健身。
There is a lot of research and there is a lot of new research that says that other things are also really useful and more cognitive mental therapies or talk therapies are useful. For me, that is not the case. look at my life and everything is actually quite spectacular and I'm very, very lucky to have what I have. For me, you can almost notice like a biological shift because nothing else in your life really changes and then suddenly you're just in this pit and you don't know how to get out. So the medication was really, really useful and it was like, it was so strange but I was almost like setting myself many daily goals. But this time it wasn't for like moving ahead in my career and it wasn't for fitness.
而是：离开房子就行。今天只做一件基本任务。只给一个人打电话。然后你就会慢慢地、稳稳地开始顺着梯子爬出洞穴。然后你又会往下掉一点点。这永远不会是线性的。但你要驾驭美好的时光。你要挺过美好时光的浪潮。我认为正常生活和经历这一切（或者经历任何非常困难、非常非常艰难的事情）的区别在于，在正常生活中，当情况哪怕只是比平时稍微好一点点时，你其实并不会真正注意到。你有点把这当成了理所当然。但当情况不那么顺利时，每一个让你微笑的小细节，每一个让你的大脑获得一丝平静和沉默的时刻——天哪，这就是我所求的一切。
It was like, just leave the house. Just do one essential task today. Just call one person. And slowly and surely you start to climb the ladder out of the hole. And then you fall back a little bit. It's never going to be linear. But you ride the good times. You ride out the wave of the good times. That's the difference between normal life and I think going through this is, or going through anything that's very difficult and very, very hard, is that in normal life, you kind of just don't really notice when things are just even a slightly bit better than they usually are. You kind of just take it for granted. But when things are going not that well, every small thing that makes you smile, every moment where you just have a bit of peace and silence in your brain, oh my gosh, that's all I ask for.
那是一种祝福，是你内心会感到无比巨大感激的事情。所以我真的顺应了那些快乐的浪潮。哪怕它只持续三分钟，或者持续一个小时，我都完全沉浸在那个时刻中。然后，（你知道的）我终于去看医生了。虽然等待的时间还是很长。有时我想：“不，他们帮不了我。我需要的我都已经知道了。”但事实并非如此。
That is a blessing and that is something that you feel incredibly immensely grateful for. So I really rode those happy waves. Even if it was for three minutes, if it was for an hour, I was fully present in that moment. And then, you know, I did finally get to see someone. It was still a long wait. And sometimes I think I'm like, no, they're not going to be able to help me. Like I already know everything I need to know. Not true.
这是一种福气，也是你会感到无比感恩的事情。所以我真的顺应了那些快乐的浪潮。哪怕只有三分钟，或者一个小时，我都完全沉浸在那个当下。然后，你知道的，我最终还是见到了一位医生。这依然是一个漫长的等待。有时我会想，不，他们不可能帮到我。好像我已经知道了所有需要知道的事情。其实并不是这样。
And it's not just about knowledge and information. It's about a different perspective and it's about having someone neutral who can really help you out. So I'm feeling a bit better now. I'm slowly coming out of it. I'm still having hard days. I was at my pottery class last night and these dark thoughts came back and I got a bit of an adrenaline jolt and a shock and felt the need to like run away and hermit again. But I pushed through. That's really all you can do at this point.
这不仅关乎知识和信息，更关乎不同的视角，关乎有一个能真正帮到你的中立之人。所以我现在感觉好一点了，正在慢慢走出来。我依然会经历艰难的日子。昨晚我在上陶艺课时，这些黑暗的想法又涌了上来，我感到一阵肾上腺素飙升和震惊，甚至想逃跑并再次自我封闭。但我挺过来了。这确实是你目前唯一能做的事。
it's when you get to that point of being at such a low, low stage and just rock bottom mentally and psychologically, and I'm sure I'll probably be there again. You just, you take everything that you can in every moment and every skill and every resource that you can muster and you take that and you put it towards just feeling even 1% better each day. And that's really, really tough and it requires strength.
当你陷入那种极端低谷、在精神和心理上跌入谷底时——我相信我以后可能还会经历这样的时刻——你会抓住每一个瞬间、竭尽所能调动所有的技能和资源，把它们全部投入到让自己每天哪怕好转1%的努力中。这真的非常、非常艰难，它需要强大的意志力。
But like that example from last night, Like you just, in some ways, have to ride the wave of the good and the bad and just let the thoughts come and let them move on. So I'm still not 100% back to normal. I don't know. It might take a little while, but things are looking up. And I wanted to be open and honest with you that this is the reality of living with mental health. It's probably, or maybe your reality as well. And we don't talk about it.
但就像昨晚的那个例子，在某种程度上，你必须顺应好与坏的浪潮，任由这些想法出现并让它们自然过去。所以我还没完全恢复到100%的正常状态。我不知道这可能需要一段时间，但情况正在好转。我想对你敞开心扉、坦诚相告，这就是与心理健康问题共存的现实，或许这也是你的现实。而我们往往不愿谈论它。
and we don't acknowledge it, and we don't see stories of it in the media unless it's someone depicted as going quote-unquote crazy, unless it's someone depicted as being violent. It's not, that's just such a simplistic view of mental health. It also looks like me, someone who knows the system, someone who talks about this all the time, still being confronted with incredibly hard thoughts to manage and not really knowing how to get out of it,
我们不愿承认它，在媒体上也看不到关于它的故事，除非某人被刻画成所谓的“发疯”，或者被刻画成具有暴力倾向。这并不是真实的写照，这种对心理健康的的看法实在是太简单化了。它其实也可能发生在我身上——一个了解心理健康体系、经常谈论这个话题的人，依然会面对极其难以应对的阴暗思绪，且不知该如何摆脱困境。
not knowing a path forward. You are not alone. You are not alone in that experience. I absolutely promise you. Please reach out to anybody and everybody. Reach out to those who love you. Reach out to mental health services. And also, if you are someone who struggles routinely with their mental health,
不知该如何找到前行的出路。你并不孤单。在经历这种感受时，你绝对不孤单。我向你保证。请向任何人、每一个人寻求帮助。向爱护你的人倾诉，向心理健康机构求助。同时，如果你是一个经常与心理健康问题抗争的人，
the best time to get care and to get health care and to get a health care and to get a a therapist or a psychiatrist is actually when you're feeling well because you cannot predict when these waves will crash over you. You cannot predict the cycles. You cannot predict when you might slip and fall back into this kind of dark space. So this is your reminder. Even if you're listening to this right now and you're like, I'm actually doing really, really fine. I'm not triggered at all, but I know I have been in the past and I have been before then. Get help when you are healthy, it will prepare you for times like the one I was in where it's an emergency and you don't have the systems in place. I know it's easier said than done and sometimes that's not even
获取关怀、医疗帮助、寻找治疗师或精神科医生的最佳时机，其实是在你感觉良好的时候，因为你无法预料这些情绪的巨浪何时会向你拍打过来。你无法预测周期，也无法预测自己何时会滑落并重新陷入这种黑暗的空间。所以这是对你的提醒。即使你此刻正在听这段节目，心里想着：“我其实过得真的、真的很好，我一点都没有被触发，但我知道我过去曾经历过，以前也经历过。”请在身体健康时寻求帮助，这会为你做好准备，迎接像我所经历的那种属于紧急情况、而你又没有建立好应对机制的时刻。我知道说起来容易做起来难，有时这些资源甚至
available to us, but if you can, it is insurance. You cannot afford to not look after your mental health. That's something that my mom said to me. She's like, you are someone who cannot afford to do this. This is like having a chronic illness. You wouldn't let your diabetes get to this point. You wouldn't let your, you know, if you were diagnosed with cancer, you wouldn't skip your follow-up appointments and to see if the cancer come back, if you're in remission or like, you wouldn't do that. So don't do it with your mental health either. It's just as valuable. I want to thank you for, I'm going to thank you in advance for your kindness and for your respect. I know that it's a private situation, but I hope by making it a bit more public, people feel seen,
并不属于我们，但如果你能做到，这就是一份保险。你承担不起不关注自己心理健康的代价。这是我妈妈对我说过的话。她说：“你是一个承担不起这样做的人。这就像患了一种慢性病。你不会任由自己的糖尿病发展到这种地步。你也不会……你知道的，如果你被诊断出癌症，你不会跳过复查不去查看癌症是否复发，如果你处于缓解期的话，你不会那样做的。”所以，对待你的心理健康也请不要这样。它同样弥足珍贵。我要感谢你，我提前感谢你的善意与尊重。我知道这是一个私人的处境，但我希望通过把它变得更加公开，能让人们觉得被看到、
people feel heard, people know how to support their loved ones, and you don't feel alone, because that would have been very, very useful for me during that time. If you have any further questions or, yeah, I would love to hear from you at that psychology podcast. You know, on Monday we will be back to regularly scheduled programming. We're going to talk about right person wrong time. So we'll be moving on. We're moving back to what we normally talk about. Thank you for giving me the space.
觉得被倾听、知道如何支持自己爱的人，并且让你觉得不孤单，因为在那段时期，如果能有这些对我会非常、非常有用。如果你有任何进一步的问题，或者，是的，我很期待在那个心理学播客听到你的声音。你知道的，周一我们将恢复常规节目编排。我们将讨论“对的人，错的时间”。所以我们要继续前行，回到我们平常讨论的话题。谢谢你为我提供空间，
to just talk at you for half an hour about my mental health. It's actually been quite therapeutic. So I appreciate the mental load that you took on of listening. Make sure that you are following along to hear more episodes. And if you enjoyed this episode, maybe you didn't. Maybe it was quite dark. I apologize. But if you enjoy the podcast in general,
让我对着你喋喋不休地谈论了半小时我的心理健康问题。这其实挺有治疗效果的。所以我很感激你倾听所承担的心理负担。请确保关注以收听更多单集。如果你喜欢这一期节目——也许你并不喜欢，也许它有些黑暗，我道歉——但如果你整体上喜欢这个播客，
please leave a five-star review. I'm going to leave some links to some services in the description. If you need them, please don't hesitate to use them. That's what they're there for. even if you think that what you're going through isn't that serious. I don't think that's for you to decide. I think that objectively, if you're struggling, you are struggling. So those services are there for you.
请留下五星好评。我会在简介中附上一些服务机构的链接。如果你需要它们，请不要犹豫去使用。它们的存在就是为了这个，即使你认为你正在经历的事情并没有那么严重。我认为这不该由你来决定。我认为客观上讲，如果你在苦苦挣扎，你就是在挣扎。所以那些服务时刻为你敞开。
Please use them. Please, please reach out for help. Be kind to yourself. Be gentle with yourself. It's all of our first times alive. And we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
请使用它们。请务必、务必寻求帮助。善待你自己，温柔对待自己。这可是我们所有人的第一次人生体验。我们很快会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side
选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇异的现代世界中，如何建立心理坚韧度、保持体能以及培养复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast, For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字的2%。可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《回看播客》中，对于1979年，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.），我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及喜爱的作家一起。就像马马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代一样。84年是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? Listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
这确实是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回看》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？收听《艰难学习》节目，主持人是你喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对算不上安全的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once.
有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试并参与其中，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranciani. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens said,
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·兰西亚尼（Michael Ranciani）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）说，
finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。